theo thông tin từ Việt k yểm sát, nhưng giờ cũng được bà dính biến bán đầu sớm đi, khoảng 2,5 hà dần
nè, hà mới thống bẩy, tại sẽ chân thành 2, 5 y tri trăm tảm lâm quay khảnh hoa, điều khiến sẽ các dự nằm
biến kiểm soát, 5 e, 1,5 hà, 2,5 hà chờ, 3,5 hà khởi hàng từ khảnh hoa để thành 4,5,
đến khoảng 2,5 hà dần nè, hà mới mốt thống bẩy khi đến khi lúc mát 1 tảm bà chiến cộng bà chăm,
có lộ một thuộc địa phần giá hơn thích thành phố đồng này, tại sẽ hài phát hiện phía trước
cũng châu có một sét ai, gió trong tình trạm bún ngủ, mất tập trung, tại sẽ đã đánh lai xong phà
để tránh bà chăm, cú đánh lai khi sẽ khác lao xong phần đường biến phài, và chạm liên
tiếp vào 2 hài thống không lần cà bà vê trong đó thành lần cà thứ 2 đâm suyên và khu vực gần
xé này mặc lên xuống biến phủ phía trước, và chạm kể đông cơ bị tắt mảy hài thống
hơi nừng hà đông nên cơ chính của xé chỉ vẫn hạnh mạng hơi không thể mở theo các thông thường,
cũng lúc này khỏi và lửa phát ra từ khu vực bật lên xuống kể trước, rồi nhân chẳng mục phát
lan ra toàn bộ xe, tài xe trên tháng hải cũng phụ xe lê cũng đặt đã phá cơ chính để được hạnh
khách giang hoài, tuy nhiên giòn ngọt lửa và khỏi lan quá nhân, các nạn nhân không thể tiếp cận biến chong để
kiểu những hài khách ở giải ghế quay, hô qua vụ tay nạc khiến bẩy hài khách từ vong, năm hài khách bị thương đa đo đều
chi, trước xe khách cũng nhiều tài xa biến chong bị trải khoan toàn sau đó tài xe trên tháng hải đã đến tông ăn sẽ
thích đầu thú, khai nhad miên nhân tài nạng gió bản thân đường ngủ và mất tập trung khi lại xem,
khiến câu quan cải sẽ được chá đăng tạm giữ trở thành hải để tục làm gió và suy lê.